hey guys I'm Greg Greg chillin on the
couch and I'm John sitting over here
we're gonna check out the trailer for a
movie based on my friendship with John
Beauty and the Beast oh boy I am clearly
the beauty in this friendship and I am a
little teacup with the chippin
yes yes and Dan Seibert is the Beast
yeah Emma Watson's in this I'm assuming
she plays Bell I don't know who's
playing Beast you know what you know
what Kelsey Grammer get shirt
get your ha get your Apple of IMDB and
then we'll look up who's directing and
who's starring in this that would have
been really good to do before Easter
after we watch the trail Oh surprises go
no don't look at it don't look you know
why are you - why are you still typing
what does that mean I'm not seeing who's
in it I'm just making sure the pages
there so I turned back on ya okay cuz
you can't edit this stuff out Zola yeah
I really like when they change the
buzzer
Sarah hi
husband
Burnie how we this be complete
look a girl yes I can see it's a girl
who what if she is the one
oh maybe some like Bing or something
dude
no don't touch it he's gonna get mad and
how happy are you yes
see my best she loved this so long from
now I know I'm sorry
okay positives are you guys ready for
some positives here looks visually
beautiful looks great like I said while
watching this I'm already hoping that we
get a theme park attraction of this it's
a good teaser trailer honestly and it
does you know set a cool kind of like
romantic mysterious dark fairy tale tone
which is pretty much what the Beauty and
the Beast cartoon is so it's on them and
it gives it a sort of a haunting and a
sort of melancholy twinge which makes it
just seem like it is different and doing
its own thing and it's an effective
teaser cuz I'm sort of wondering now
like is the movie gonna have this kind
of atmosphere is it gonna really pay
attention to the scenery the same way a
movie like crimson like a Clarke fantasy
I really hope me guest on is in this
he's my favorite hey you know that thing
you were taking forever
uh-huh hold up hey Luke Evans your boy
he's gonna die yes you know kind of sick
of Luke Evans what how's that even
possible all the guy from the guest is
playing the because Luke Evans isn't a
lot of roles that no one really
remembers true although he's my favorite
part of the Hobbit guess not what yeah
Bart is alright
actually no let's I take that way back
yeah I'm really wondering what the
effects of the beast are gonna look like
I wonder if is gonna Godzilla this
trailer up you know uh-huh
family toys and you don't really see the
beast and the trailers I don't think
this will happen I think they'll do that
thing where they give us one shot at the
very end but it would be cool if they
didn't show the Beast or at least only
show the beast in parts you know I hope
he's horrifying to look at I hope he is
completely unbelievable that they could
ever phone exactly exactly you know and
if they can win us over with that
personality it goes to them and you know
when he does become human and if it
follows the Disney card
if it becomes human again it's a good
thing he's really good-looking
underneath all that fur him a little
skeptical of these kinds of movies but
like since the jungle book seemed to
have worked I really love the jungle
book and since I heard Cinderella was
really good like I'm caught I'll be
cautiously optimistic about this yeah
never Watson you know she she isn't you
know she has a little bit of experience
with fantasy yeah that's true yeah this
is did dedicate like ten years of her
life to fantasy it's a great career move
for Emma Watson I think for someone
who's been you know like the three kids
have been transitioning out of the Harry
Potter image Daniel Radcliffe seems to
be doing the best job at the mall Emma
Watson's done some work here and there
that people liked but you know she still
is Hermione and a lot of people's eyes I
think that this is the perfect
transition for her to like go into
another fantasy film but with a
different character who's the lead and
they're still familiar terra-tory here
yeah Emma Watson good job there was a
picture where you see her vagina when
she's getting out of a car yeah I knew
wasn't pretty
thank you rather disappointed Emma mmm
I'm kidding you have attacked her
I don't know what it look like I'm
kidding I'm sure you have a nice nice
crotch Emma
no oh yeah it could be I'm curious it be
a nice crotch penis no as a career move
for her because the thing is like for a
career move show the crotch it's nicer
best way to boost sales in the ticket
department yeah yeah gotcha
uh-huh so what we're gonna do mm-hmm
anything else want if this movie is more
like snowing the Huntsman and you know
crimson peak or something like that
where it's like you know bigger and more
Hollywood style that would go in a
different direction and you know I'm
curious to see what kind of move this is
I guess what I'm trying to say is I
can't tell if this is gonna be more
along those fantasy lines or more along
the like we're gonna really take this
story you know seriously but with a
human touch like The Jungle Book what I
would like to is for some of the musical
numbers to be in there incorporated in
the way how the jungle book did it yeah
this this one has a markedly different
tone because I thought the way they did
it in The Jungle Book was pretty natural
even though the jungle book gets serious
it's still got a lightness and an
adventure to it and they very much
advertised that so when the music the
backup music kicks in it makes sense
this to me I'm a little more I would
love to see them incorporate the music
in a much more grounded kind of way
maybe more they're just all singing
together or something like that so it
really it changes it but it really
matches the decorum I would like to see
a very realistic interpretation of
Beauty and the Beast the film would be
about five minutes long where Belle
confronts the beast and the Beast just
tears it apart and that's the end quick
and simple make it one series five
minutes yeah bills demolished head torn
off and then takes Lumiere
pour some gasoline on her lights on fire
and then Gaston stands in the background
laughing and then it turns out that
Belen and Ariel actually you know like
went to college together and they were
like you know super close so then the
sequel Ariel comes to avenge fells death
yeah that's the look yeah it's like I
need legs yeah you can't talk though I
need all kinds of legs she's back which
is like a hundred legs make a crazy
spider hit listen Jews and Christians
and Muslims and atheists for knew the
channel subscribe today was a religion
I'm missing I don't really know John yes
is a [ __ ]
I hate reasons to Jerry [ __ ] face and he
also has bloom house calm social media
manager on there no it is not nudie pics
of Jones stop commenting asking why
isn't blue house
calm show me some nudie takes a jump
because it's not what the site's about
it's about horror movies and you know
yeah it's horror it's a horror theme
suck so cut it out those are only some
time iPhone I'm not touching that one
touch it
no I touch it hello you why do you own
right just kill
why don't I own Righteous Kill